[Music]
[Music]
my father was Saawariya
and they used to kill many many many
Lancia he used to tell me how dangerous
Lancer I used to hate Lance
[Music]
when I was a young boy I thought I will
be growing up and killing Lance but now
we protect the lives because if there is
no Lance in-sample it's no life
[Music]
[Applause]
we found an armored truck so we think is
in the area now so we're going to look
for her now you gonna do that already
Marie we just got our signal so just
scanning around enough see if she's
still there northern Kenya is one of the
few places in the world where you can
see livestock wildlife people all living
together
but when Lions are struggling to find
food they come into contact with local
communities and often will target
livestock so January have said to me if
we want to stop people killing lions
we've got to engage this warrior
demographic he came up with our program
which is called warrior watch
for centuries our tribe depend on their
livestock for their livelihood so as a
warrior we provided security for our
livestock and protect livestock from
land we call I'll in the morning before
the last of our list and see where the
lines are we know the lands are in the
area we go back and spread that
awareness within the community so that
they can avoid those areas the same
style we use to kill the lands now we
use that knowledge to protect the lens
[Music]
my tribe are very grateful for warriors
program because that will save their
livestock and also will save the lion
society our goal is to promote
coexistence between people and lions in
northern Kenya and make sure that we
respond to everything that's happening
and that the Lions are safe during this
very critical time we have never seen
the river dry at this time of the year
there is no enough water to sustain
people on world life it's a really
really challenging time right now
communities are struggling to take their
livestock into areas to find enough
grazing there's no water for any of the
animals both livestock and Wildlife
the water is undergone and and this is
how we get water for both were livin in
our list and also for people these how
we are surviving
[Music]
someone of just colas and say that he
had the cancer so we're just going there
and check to see if people are shooting
those lines
[Music]
the Warriors will respond as soon as
they ever hear from any of their network
that gunshots have been heard or there's
any conflict the guys responds so
quickly
cows have just come to bland habitant
and the lands are very scan the lands of
scared of the cows because of people
they know that we kill cows people
nope winner
what would the new
[Music]
so we found out that when they let's
talk wire drinking water then the
elephant came there so people who are
shooting up on the air to scare their
fans away I'm still you know concern
about the world life in general but
luckily it was not Lance because we have
so few Lance Lions can live with people
coexistence is possible as long as the
people are willing to accept the lion
presence and that's what's happened in
the last couple of years people have
accepted Lions tolerated them the Lions
feel areas that they're safe in and
they've just recovered in areas where
they never used to be if you want to
make a difference if you want why life
to succeed involve the people are living
with wildlife because really that's the
key to their success here at the Samburu
communities are the ones protecting the
wildlife and I have a lot of hope
because of that I'm hoping that my
community accepting lands so there'll be
Lions for the future generations
[Music]
[Music]